I am currently anemic, iron levels, iron saturation, ferritin, hemoglobin, magnesium to name a few.
What's a good source of iron supplementation?
I'm taking a cestral blood supplementation, supplements right now.
Olvine grass fed, freeze dried products, I'm familiar with these.
These you could still use.
Also, the other thing that you could go on is a good iron as well.
The products that you are using right now are an iron product.
But it's a whole food iron product which can be good and can be beneficial.
But just getting iron in a source like I'm going to show you in just a second might be something to add to the product.
It's clear iron that I would say would be a choice and this is it right there.
So clear iron is the is the fairichelle that's the brand name fairichelle is this is the.
Designs for health uses fairichelle a number of companies use fairichelle it is a product that is created.
As a this glycinate double bonded member all your minerals have to be double bonded to an amino acid and typically they use glycine because that's what's found in nature.
So it's well absorbed and well used.
However, if you're going to take iron I always suggest that you add or to miss it in with it as well because cancer can double up iron that's why many cancer patients.
Are low and iron and end up with anemia because the cancer is gobbling up iron so it seems counter to a tip that I'm going to add iron to help with by anemia if I could possibly be feeding the cancer well it is when you have to we have to walk that tight rope.
You can't you know stay in anemic state that's not good for us either not good for our healing.
So if you're going to add iron even the ancestral product that you're currently taking I would say an Artemisidant as well.
Why Artemisidant because Artemisidant kind of tail wigs with iron and it will drag the iron will drag the Artemisidant with it to the cancer and Artemisidant can be a cancer killer so.
So if the Artemisidant is a is something that it goes right along with iron it is carried with iron so take Artemisidant along with your higher if you're taking the iron.